gary was an iconic chef he was an icon
of British cuisine at sea to be fair
Gary was the chef that really
revolutionised British food because
we're all trained to French classical
way the style of French cuisine Gary as
well was it was a classically trained
chef in the style of French cuisine but
he decided to talk and cook just about
English cookery so he really did
revolutionize our thinking about the way
we cook food here so things like foods
like fish cakes
oxtail things that had fallen out of
fashion because of him we are eating a
lot more of those things today that's
right he really took the old style
recipes that were basically British
recipes that mums and grounds used to
cook them did them very well and he put
them in front of restaurants as he put
them in front of our customers the
classic fish and chips the pies there
the beautiful puddings that were so
well-known for Gary really brought them
to the forefront I first met him with
when we used to do the channel that
Carlton Food Network the network the
Food Network channel early early days
for me 30 years ago 25 years ago when we
started doing television I mean in those
days you know you cooked in kitchens and
then if you've got spotted that maybe
someone would put would give you the
chance to be on television but the guy
was a genius because he was so natural
in front of a camera I don't know anyone
there was as natural as him he was a
great presenter as well it made it very
generous when you went on his shows
always made me feel a home even you know
when we did when we did Coakley shows
together he was just a genius and I'm
not just saying this I think the man
will be a big miss especially losing him
as young as he was as he is he was and
you know I feel I've really filled for
his family today oh oh I just remember
the little banter that we used to have
and you know he was a big supporter of
Manchester United and I was asked know
we always used to sort of text one
another about the results and stuff like
that but I think I remember him for more
for what he did for British cuisine you
know at a time when everyone thought
that you know British food was terribly
flat he took the simple rest
peas that we associate with Britain like
you mentioned earlier on the fantastic
bread and butter pudding and transformed
them into something quite magical you
know I love the fact that he took black
pudding and put a poached egg with it
and it seems so sort of casual now in
this day and age but 20-30 years ago
Gary brought it to our screens then we
wanted it on our tables we want you to
go out and buy those books and let's not
forget to say that was a time when you
know people were embarrassed to have
their a cookery book in front of them
unless it was mrs. Beeton or something
like that
nobody wanted a you know to be
associated with it and he opened the
door food became trendy he got those
young Chefs people who were home
thinking about becoming cooks and
thinking I can go to work with my hair a
little bit spiky I can have a little bit
of furniture on my myface if I want you
know a little tattoo or something like
that he just changed our attitude